INTERVIEWER: The symbolism
of the elaborate iron
gates in front of Nassau Hall
has evolved over the years.
When FitzRandolph Gate
was installed in 1905,
the gates beautified
front campus
but acted as a barrier between
the University and the town.
Opened only for occasional
guests and University events,
FitzRandolph Gate remained
closed for 65 years
until 1970, when students
requested that the gates stand
permanently open as the symbol
of the University's openness
to the community.
It was then, as students began
celebrating their Commencement
by marching through the gate
into the postcollegiate world,
that the rumors surrounding
FitzRandolph Gate started forming.
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER:
I think
the FitzRandolph myth has
become a very important part
of student culture.
As I was walking out
to this interview,
there was an Orange Key
group assembled right
on the Nassau Hall
steps, and the guide
was telling them that if
they walked out the gate,
they were never
going to graduate.
And I held up my hands and
said, hey, I walked out of it
all the time when I
was an undergraduate.
It worked out OK.
But I think they probably
believed the guide rather than
me.
ASA CRAIG: Us graduate
students don't necessarily
know the full story of the myth.
MARCUS JOHNSON: So I didn't
even know the gate had a name
until like two weeks ago.
PRISCILLA YEUNG: The myth is
that you cannot walk through
the main center gate of
FitzRandolph Gate, otherwise,
you will not graduate.
But you are allowed to
walk in the center gate,
and you are allowed to walk
through the side gates.
RYAN STOFFERS: I know there's
a gate that you're not really
supposed to walk in, because
it'll make you not graduate
or graduate late, but
I haven't taken it
too seriously in my time here.
GARRETT BAIRD: This
is one of the things
that, like, you don't actually
know, because if someone does
walk through the gate,
and they don't graduate,
you don't really see
them around, I guess.
SHANNON OSAKA:
Sometimes people say
that you won't graduate
at all, but I've
heard you won't graduate
within four years.
MONIQUE CLAIBORNE: It's
a Princeton tradition
that you walk outside of
the big FitzRandolph Gates
with your entire class
right after Commencement,
and you can finally officially
leave the orange bubble,
the bubble was
broken and whatnot,
but JFK was a little
rebellious and actually walked
outside of the FitzRandolph
Gates before Commencement.
And because of that,
he got really sick,
failed all of his classes, was
forced the transfer to Harvard.
And we really want to
graduate from Princeton.
We definitely don't
want to go to Harvard.
So we really tried to wait
until right after Commencement
to walk outside the gates
with our entire class.
BERNADO DA SILVA: I
have a few friends who
in spite of knowing
the myth, they
refuse to let it stop them
and they just bravely walk
through the central gates.
And they can do that.
They can do that
whatever they want to do,
but I'm going to stick to it
to what I'm comfortable with
and use the side gates
until at least June 6th.
EMILY AVERY: When we do
finally walk through the gates,
that'll be the sign that
we've really made it,
and that we're moving
on to the next step.
So I'm really excited for it.
ASA CRAIG: The idea
behind the myth
is really around a shared,
sort of, sense of community,
and so if everyone
has this idea of,
hey, we're going to get
through together, get
through Princeton, get
through writing our thesis,
it make sense to really get a
communal understanding of what
it means to
experience this place
and to go out into the world.
BERNADO DA SILVA:
My accomplishments
are definitely in
a way my parents
and family's accomplishments,
they've given me so much --
given up so much so
that I can have a lot
and that I can be
here at Princeton
and have these
great opportunities.
SAMI WALTER: There's so
many great traditions
that bring people together
like the thesis experience
and freshman orientation, etc.
And I can still remember
that first day, the people
I was sitting with in the
chapel, and the people
I walked through the gate with.
MARY HELEN DEGOLIAN: I think
one of the things I really
appreciated about
Princeton is how, like, you
can't go a day without
learning something new.
SHANNON OSAKA: You're exposed
to so many things all the time.
And you have so many
opportunities to go to a talk,
to go to a show, to
sit in on a lecture class
that you're not even taking.
MARY HELEN DEGOLIAN:
Kind of in the abstract,
my hopes for graduation
are to keep that, like,
love of learning and that,
like, continual learning even
in my career.
VIVIAN CHANG: And I think a
lot of us graduate students,
undergrads, are thinking
about the same things.
How do I change the world?
How do I bring my full self
into everything I'm doing?
MONIQUE CLAIBORNE:
Once you leave,
you feel like you're not
just part of those four class
years that have been part
of your experience here,
but you're actually part of a
many, many years before you,
and you're still
part of many years
to come after you as well.
RYAN STOFFERS: I think that
one of the great strengths
of Princeton, especially
the Woodrow Wilson School
is the alumni community.
I know they've been
immensely helpful to me
throughout my time here.
Always willing to answer
questions, have meetings,
connect me with
people that they know.
And so I think that when
I go out through the gate,
and I'm on the
other side then I'll
be in that role helping
current students however I can.
And I'm looking forward to when
I get my first current student
reaching out to me and asking
questions about my career
or how I can help them,
and I'll be happy to.
COLIN LUALDI: I hope with
my future work in physics
that I can encourage more
deaf youth to get involved
in advanced stem research, and
we'll see, maybe one of them
will win the Nobel Prize.
MARCUS JOHNSON: So I really
hope that through my research
and also my work
in the classroom
that I really continue
to be able to empower
the next generation of
underrepresented scholars
in political science
and also to enrich
the experience of students that
are traditionally represented
in higher education.
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER
You've accomplished a lot here,
and all of us at Princeton
are excited to see
what you're going to do in the
world beyond FitzRandolph Gate
and excited to welcome you
back when you come back
to Princeton University.
[MUSIC PLAYING]